I'm Sarah Nolan I'm 24 years old and I
serve as an AmeriCorps fellow at Habitat
for Humanity
I make 19 K over 11 months math just
wasn't adding up and I realize despite
my hatred of paperwork and despite the
fact that it made me kind of
uncomfortable I had to apply for food
stamps
I just dished out way more than 99 cents
on to see ya good I'm looking at
different apple varieties and pounds and
how much it costs per pound and trying
to do some mental math which is not
exactly my strong suit where'd you go
shopping yesterday I went to Trader
Joe's I also went to the farmers market
which you can shop at the farmers market
on food Stanley yeah so you're looking
at price I'm looking at price instead of
I have this desire to buy organic I
agree with it too but also you know
occasionally got buy stuff and I'll take
the stickers off so my roommates don't
know one way or the other if it's real
they're gonna get mad at me if it's not
organic can even buy organic vanilla
extract
I can go comparison shopping if I was
like the head of a household and I was
really busy and I was working two jobs
multiple shifts I think it'd be way
harder to eat healthy were there things
that were like you thought all those
luxuries before then that you can get
are you did you just learn to my gosh
I bought good cheese yesterday it was
really exciting
I think it's a big conundrum it's not
just solved by like having enough money
for food so food stamps get you part of
the way there but it's hard I make about
750 every two weeks and I spent 750 of
it on rent a month I mean a lot of
people will say well you have a youth
degree from Duke University you could
easily be making a salary way more than
nineteen thousand a year and not being
on food stamps what do you say to that I
felt really bad about being on food
stamps for a while they're just for
people who really really need it I
thought and I'm like living this
flippant lifestyle San Francisco do you
think you're really really needed well
yeah and eventually I just sort of
realize that even though I'm 24 like I
still have responsibilities I still have
like hopes for my future and if I need
to be on food stamps makes it happen
then maybe I do really need it but
zucchini okay should I do it here yeah
okay so I'm sort of torn because I am
like using the same services a lot of
our beneficiaries people that I work for
habitat but like it's strange to be in
the same programs the people I'm helping
are in and I feel like did I really
succeed with my Duke degree if I'm at
this point like part of the reason I'm
doing like sacrifice too I do it because
I like it like I like talking to people
about what's going on in their lives
like it more than selling people for an
ax shirt is what I did last year things
they don't maybe need you made more
money doing that oh yeah definitely made
like a normal Bay Area salary then and I
was in a position like we're talking
about really everywhere it's privileged
enough to do something different take a
risk like I'm 24 there's definitely a
fat stake like I shouldn't be complacent
and job I don't like but I can still
fail a couple more times and hopefully
figure it out from there
do you consider yourself part of the
working poor yes I am working and I am
currently low income
I think the difference for me and a lot
of other Millennials as we see it
is transitory like I have more friends
and I initially would have thought that
are on food stamps or couchsurfing
instead of living somewhere a lot of
people make sacrifices to sort of be on
the right path and sometimes it takes
you to these sorts of places where
you're on food stamps what is a food
stamp first thing is these days they're
not actually stamped but government
debit cards they're given to people with
low income to buy an average of one
hundred and twenty-five dollars worth of
food per month